hello there recently we looked at What
secrets and Easter eggs can be found by
standing still and leaving your
controller alone in video games in the
comments of that video people shared
other examples of unique things that can
happen so we have to make a part two of
literally doing nothing
oh
an Easter egg was found in Gran Turismo
7 when a player randomly stopped on the
mount Panorama circuit while making
lunch when he came back 10 minutes had
passed and look in the distance an alien
UFO visits on race day and takes a cow
as a souvenir it was then discovered
that there are many locations in the
game where these Alien Invasion signs
could be spotted and by sitting and
waiting at one of these spots for up to
20 minutes the aliens will arrive and
take a different animal I don't think
the otter was expecting that we all know
about Mario falling asleep and different
birds landing on his face in Mario
Odyssey well did you know that Mario has
over 40 voice lines when asleep
review
turkey
it's so true Mario will begin listing
types of pasta dishes and the occasional
Mamma Mia too pretty amazing
sticking with Nintendo Link's outfit can
be swapped out in a breath of the wild
to create this topless Link in cold
biomes he'll begin shivering yet to
leave him alone long enough in warmer
climates and he'll eventually begin
flexing his muscles yeah Metal Gear
Solid Snake Eater is set for a remake
yet in the original an AFK secret can be
found one boss fight has snake face off
with a veteran sniper named the end it's
a slow paced tactical fight a secret was
found by literally doing nothing for a
week when the boss fight begins log off
your game and go live your life and
seven days later by logging in again the
enemy will have died of old age this
could be the easiest boss fight in video
game history maybe it was from old age
you really kicked the bucket in the
middle of a battle street fighter 6 is
crammed with details but one can only be
seen by staying completely still with
Ryu on his stage wait long enough and
his Idol animation perfectly lines up
with the stages changing music
foreign
I love stuff like that
speaking of Street Fighter back in the
day if you stop playing long enough in
the background you'll notice these two
NPCs this couple are here to enjoy the
action yet if a female fighter has been
picked this will happen she does not
approve of whatever he's looking at and
he takes one to the face in another
fighter Tekken Tag Tournament 2 wait
around long enough in the historic town
stage and you'll see a chicken atop of
the cat stood on a dog standing on a
donkey these are a reference to the town
Musicians of Bremen a German fairy tale
a couple of hundred years old even
heroes like Gordon Freeman can't help
themselves sometimes should you pick up
a snack in Half-Life and leave the
keyboard alone for a while Gordon won't
be able to resist touching the little
alien being he doesn't look impressed in
the black Mesa unofficial remake those
animations were updated and included
these and we don't talk about the time
he was played with like a toy doll
to go on a mission on Earth and simply
stand around AFK in the mothership
suddenly your commanding officer will
say this didn't anyone tell you the name
of the game is Destroy All Humans not
screw around on the Mothership
do something already he's got a point
you know if you were ever playing the
campaign in GTA 5 take the time to visit
the cemetery staying here during
daylight hours will give you this very
sad sight a dog will visit every single
day and head straight for its owner's
grave site and stay there until bedtime
every single day and it never stops this
is based on a real life story greyfriars
Bobby a sky Terrier who stood guard by
his owner's grave for 14 years and we
learned about this by going AFK
as well as hugely impressive Idol
animations some are just silly little
details that someone had to sit down and
code in such as Desmond in the
Assassin's Creed series leave him long
enough and he'll sort out his underwear
issue some sort of wedgie going on there
[Music]
whereas Thanos in Lego Marvel will get
so bored he takes a nap on his iconic
throne but my guy gets a little bit
agitated and doesn't know his own
strength
but for me Earthworm Jim takes this to
the next level with secret versions of
his Idol animations Jim would usually
Flex his muscles and spin his gun like a
pro yet there is a chance both could go
wrong resulting in this flexing his
muscles and his pants fall down and
taking one to the face doesn't look fun
but things can get much worse over in
jazz Jackrabbit 2 which is a literal
poster in fortnite right now if Jazz
stands AFK for too long a bird will fly
down to visit him and you'll never guess
what he does next
wow dinner time in a hat in time there
are a bunch of idol animations yet one
is a bit more eye-catching than the rest
it's possible for two dolls to be
brought out and share a kiss which then
becomes a little bit more the look on
her face proves she wasn't aware anyone
was watching but we were some Idol
animations involve audio like Prince of
Persia the Two Thrones stand around
afking for long enough and you'll hear
this yes yes you make a fantastic statue
can we move now quite foolish standing
around like this
oh
if you'd like to hear less aggressive
words then visit Goat Simulator 3 and
you'll stumble across a yoga class and
there's an achievement here a trophy for
staying for the entire four minutes the
thing is if we move a single muscle at
any point the yoga instructor forces
everyone to start all over again my
third eye was almost open and now it's
closed because someone moved it took me
11 times to figure that out
[Music]
in the deliberately low budget Pizza
Tower game a secret Easter egg can be
found by simply not pressing anything on
the start screen for 40 seconds we
should be turning on a light but if we
leave the lights completely out in the
room this will eventually happen
sorry about that jump scare alert did
you know that Peter Tower was inspired
by Wario Land and in Wario Land 2 on The
Game Boy Color there is another AFK
secret one of Wario's first missions is
an elaborate run into the dungeons below
his house to fight and turn off his
alarm clock yet we can skip all that by
sleeping through the alarm do not move a
muscle and the mission will auto
complete cause sleeping in is awesome
but you'll still have to complete all
the other stages to see the end credits
whereas in bendy and the dark Revival
there's a super secret shortcut ending
and yep it's done by doing nothing at
the beginning of the game after the
introduction the character wants to get
up and get some coffee no way I'm
getting through tonight without some
coffee probably some downstairs however
if you ignore the prompt for long enough
in fact it's 20 minutes they'll
eventually just forget about it and go
back to their day job well
coffee is good now but this works gotta
get done focus on her Focus triggering
one of the most boring secret endings in
the history of video games
and finally let's check in with CJ in
GTA San Andreas if left AFK long enough
he'll first start stretching but soon
he'll start singing lines from his
favorite songs here's a little bit of
each see if you can identify them
express yourself cause I'm from Grove
Street never going to get it never gonna
get it the arch take your time and let
me love you good warm it up Kane warm it
up CJ warm it up kane hey yo you dropped
the bomb on me
can't start
nothing but a cheat thing baby I think
that's enough CJ for one day I imagine
you're awesome it's been a pleasure
that was